- Hi, I'm Rie. Welcome
back to Make it Fancy.
Let's see what I'm making fancy today.
- Hi, Rie. It's Janna.
And I am challenging you
to make Jollibee fancy.
Jollibee was the first
Filipino fast food restaurant
that I've ever been to.
And they're killing it.
I especially love the Chickenjoy.
I can't wait to see what you come up with
and good luck, Rie.
- Jollibee.
I love Jollibee.
This is my favorite fast food restaurant.
Honestly, I don't think
Jollibee needs any improvement
but this is Make It Fancy.
Chickenjoy comes with fried
chicken, gravy, and white rice.
I was invited to a party.
My friend brought like hundreds
of Jollibee chicken basket
and that was my first
time to meet Jollibee.
The skin is crispy and
chicken is so juicy.
(drumstick crunches)
It's so good and so tender.
Just being Asian having
rice with fried chicken
makes sense to me.
Chickenjoy is already a perfect meal
so I have to make something
very unexpected and surprising.
I'm excited to Make It Fancy.
(cheerful music)
All right. Here's what I got.
Scallions, chives, celery,
king trumpet mushroom,
Napa cabbage, shallots, ground
pork, ginger, and garlic.
From the pantry I got
peanut oil, canola oil,
olive oil, sesame oil,
flour, white vinegar, salt,
five-spice powder, Sichuan chili
flakes, Sichuan peppercorn,
toasted sesame seeds, xanthan
gum, soy sauce, and sake.
All right, let's get started.
Make It Fancy.
First ingredient, Chickenjoy.
Keep some little surgery.
Separate chicken skin. Easily comes off.
Separate meat from the bone.
I like thigh better
flavor-wise but I feel like
if you order breast, comes with more food.
It's life hack.
Put chicken bone, one shallot,
one stalk celery, and ginger slices.
Three cloves of garlic, two cups of water
into pressure cooker.
One pinch of salt.
Cook this for 60 minutes.
(metal clanging)
Wait, how does this work?
60 minutes later my stock is ready.
Smells good. And I'm going to strain.
Now I wanna taste it.
Needs much more salt.
I made a delicious Jollibee broth
and I'm gonna set it aside
and move on the next step.
Two cups of oil.
One minced shallot, five
cloves of minced garlic,
two tablespoon of Sichuan peppercorn.
For those who never
had Sichuan peppercorn,
it kind of tingles your tongue and lips.
It's really fun flavor and sensation.
Cook this in low and slow.
About 15 minutes until the
temperature goes 215 degree
and shallot is a little bit
crisped up, but not too brown.
It has been cooking about 15 minutes
and I'm going to use the
skin I removed earlier.
Chop kind of same size as the shallot.
I made a video about bees for Tasty.
I went to somebody's backyard
and he was making honey.
So I know one or two things about bees.
- [Producer] Jollibee, the
mascot, has a girlfriend.
- Is she butterfly?
[Producer] - She's not an insect.
(both laughs)
- [Rie] Add this into the oil.
Cook another 15 minutes until
shallot is crispy and golden.
I have Sichuan pepper,
three fourth cup of chili flake,
one and half teaspoon
of five spice powder,
one teaspoon of salt.
And I'm going to pour over.
Mix well. Let it sit at least 30 minutes.
I'm going to use all rice
came in the Chickenjoy box.
Add two tablespoon of water.
Pulse until like a paste texture.
Scrape on the side, and I'm
going to add water as needed.
(blender roars)
Add in the bowl.
This looks good, but this
still needs more ingredients.
I have 120 gram of flour.
Add 60 gram of the rice paste I made.
Three full teaspoon of xanthan gum,
and the xanthan gum is kind of additive.
It helps hold the shape together.
Four tablespoon of water,
two teaspoon of olive oil.
Mix everything together.
And once it started coming together,
I'm going to knead by hand.
Use a little bench flour.
Jollibee rice dough is a little bit rough
because, you know, even we
process in food processor there,
it's like a little bit grain rice.
I think it's still pretty good.
Taste would be nice 'cause
rice is a little sweet,
but we will see.
So I'm going to knead until the dough
is a little bit smoother on the surface.
I think this is good,
almost like a pasta dough.
It is a little bit smooth and bouncy.
Put it in the bowl, cover it with plastic,
and rest for 30 minutes.
So I have fried chicken meat.
I'm going to mince.
- [Producer] Rie, when do
you think Jollibee came out?
- 1987.
- [Producer] 1978.
- [Rie] Put chicken in the bowl.
Half pound of ground pork,
one cup of chopped Napa cabbage,
half cup of king trumpet mushroom,
quarter cup of chives,
two tablespoon gravy,
one tablespoon of soy sauce,
half tablespoon of sesame oil.
Grate two cloves of garlic,
grate half teaspoon of ginger.
One tablespoon of sake.
Mix everything with using my hand.
Just make sure everything combines well.
I think filling is ready
but I have more stuff to do.
I have the dough I've been resting.
Sprinkle some flour on the surface.
Roll this out into one long log.
I'm going to cut this.
I'm cutting them into pieces.
Roll it out into circular.
You have to do it from
the side 'cause the center
should be a little bit
thicker than the edge,
'cause you are folding in.
I think dough is actually
working pretty good.
Cover with plastic while
I'm working on other dough
so it doesn't dry out.
You want to make about
four to five inches circle.
It's not like making cookie.
If you rolling at once,
outside is getting a little bit thicker.
So you want to make it outside
it's thinner than the center.
All right, it's time to get fancy.
(enchanting violin music)
I made dumplings.
Let's fry them up.
One tablespoon of oil.
Put this in the pan.
Heat up the pan over medium-high heat.
Sear the dumpling until
it has a nice brown color
on the bottom.
Cook them in batches because
I don't want to crowd the pan.
After you get nice brown
color on the bottom,
add three tablespoon of Jollibee broth,
and cook dumpling about five minutes
or until inside it's completely cooked.
All the chicken stock is evaporated.
Dough it looks a little bit bake.
And I think it's ready.
Transfer to the tray and
I'm going to cook the rest.
I made a dumpling filling
with Jollibee fried
chicken's meat and gravy.
I made dumpling wrapper
using Jollibee's rice.
Chili oil using Jollibee
fried chicken crispy skin.
Let's plate. Nice and crispy.
Pour chili oil and some
sesame seeds garnish.
And, we are done.
(slow melodic music)
Jollibee dumpling with
chili oil. Very fancy.
(upbeat music)
Welcome Janna, to Make It Fancy.
- Thank you. Oh my God.
This is like dream being on here.
(Rie cheers)
- So I'm so happy you challenged
me and I made dumpling.
- Is this real?
I mean not surprised that
you would make this fancy
but I did not expect dumplings.
- [Both] Cheers.
- [Rie] Mm.
- [Janna] Mm.
This is Jollibee?
- Mhm.
- I didn't know Jollibee
could be this fancy.
Filipinos are the firm believer
of the Jollibee supremacy.
It's so cool that you
were able to take Jollibee
and make it into something
completely different,
and new and exciting.
It's like a perfect like
fusion of two cultures.
Maybe Jollibee could take some notes.
- So, Janna did I make
Jollibee Chickenjoy fancy?
- A thousand percent fancy.
- Thousand percent.
- By the way, I love
this Make It Fancy merch.
- Thank you. You can get it.
ShopMakeItFancy.com
- Oh, there's even a website. Okay.
- All right. We have
one last things to do.
- It's the dance?
- Yes.
3, 2, 1.
- [Both] Make It Fancy.
- I went the other way.
- (soft Jazz music)